And now the old scout master.
So this summer at Scout Camp, what a wonderful time we had.
I was talking with the aquatics director and you know we were just talking, and he said,
yeah, he was a little aggravated because he had to stop one of the scouts from peeing
in the pool that morning.
I know it's kind of unpleasant, but you know it does happen.
And I said: you know how do you do that?
I mean, I said you know, I guess probably a lot of boys end up doing that,
Don't they?
He says yeah, but not when they're standing on the diving board.
Hey, this is podcast number 90..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, let's take a look and see what came through the wires this week.
First of all, Anne Voyageur. Anne Voyageur left a comment over on iTunes
Says about the podcast: a wealth of knowledge on all matters of scouting.
I've been inspired, learned, laughed and enjoyed every minute of these podcasts.
Please keep them coming.
They're great.
Well, thank you, Anne Voyageur.
I do appreciate the vote of confidence there.
I also heard from Tom Brewer and he is up in Ottawa, Ontario, Canada,
where he's a beaver scout leader in the third Orleans beaver colony
and the third Orleans scout group
And he just got in touch to tell me the story that you heard just before during the opening.
So if you liked it, it goes to Tom's credit.
If you didn't, you know I'll get in touch with Tom and tell him,
And he wrote to thank me for the podcast and says that he always enjoys them.
So this morning I'm putting together things for the podcast, getting ready to do my recording,
And I get an email question and I think the email question that I got is important enough
that we need to spend some real time talking about it,
So it's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
I'm working on a couple of interviews and some more information about the new guide to advancement
and the new Eagle Project workbook, because I think these also are tremendously important things.
I had a couple of posts about realistic expectations for scouts and some things that are new in the
Advancement Guide, and we're going to spend more time talking about those. but we're going
to use this podcast to address this email question first and that'll be coming up in
just a second.
As a matter of fact, it takes up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Hi, I'm Kevin Callan and I'm listening to
the Scout Master podcast.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Write me a letter, send it my name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
This week I heard from John Sloan via email.
John's a scout master and he had this question to ask.
He says my troop had a camp out this past weekend.
I had adults camp where we could hear the scouts if they were loud, but could not
see anything other than lantern and firelight.
I loved the idea of us being separated from them to let them do their own thing, and it
worked out very well.
The boys loved it and they had a great time.
They ended up way behind schedule, but they achieved most of what they set out to do.
The setup was quite different from what they've been used to.
I've only been scout master since April and this was the first time I was really able
to get us adults completely away from them.
My father is the troop committee chairman and thinks I need to be in camp with the boys
at all times.
He's supportive of my push for a true boy led troop, but he doesn't really trust them
to be on their own on camp outs.
When I was discussing this with my wife. she suggested that my dad did have a point.
How am I supposed to ensure their safety if I'm not there with them?
She is concerned because something very bad can happen very quickly.
She's right, it can.
I didn't have a great answer for her.
All I really have is that I trust them to act like scouts and be safe.
Accidents can happen whether I'm watching them happen or not,
But I'm not sure that any of that would fly with a parent when their son is in
the hospital getting stitches. and they found out I was drinking coffee
at another campsite when the accident occurred.
So, long story short, how do you ensure that boys are safe on a camp out
when you're not in their campsite with them?
John, that is a fantastic question and I really appreciate you getting in touch
and I hope that I'll be able to answer it thoroughly for you.
How do you do what I suggest,
And that is to let the boys camp from a distance from the adults
so that they can do their thing and maintain safety.
So let's discuss exactly how this should happen.
Well, John, I've got to tell you your father is right and your wife is right.
They're smart people, but you already knew that,
And you are right.
Everything that you wrote is perfectly valid and we need to reconcile them all together.
The short answer is: we understand and assess the risks of the particular activity
that we are undertaking
And then we take all prudent measures to mitigate those risks.
We're never going to eliminate them, but we're going to take every prudent measure
that we can to mitigate them.
You know, scouts are boys and boys are infamously bad assessors of risk.
They can be careless and inattentive and naive and they may disregard safety measures.
The ever-present question is: how do we manage this risk appropriately
while we still allow scouts the latitude to be scouts?
The BSA has given us some excellent tools to do this,
And the best one for the purposes of this discussion is the Suite 16 of BSA Safety.
If you are unfamiliar with that, you need to get familiar with it,
And I will have a link to the Suite 16 of BSA Safety
in the post that contains this podcast at scoutmastercgcom.
If we follow the procedures and policies in the Suite 16,
we're going to mitigate or limit risks our scouts are exposed to.
Now we're not going to eliminate them, but we are going to mitigate them
and we're going to keep them safe.
Now I'm not going to try and go through all 16 points here,
but I'm going to point out a couple that help to answer John's question.
The first point of the Suite 16 is qualified supervision,
and I'm going to read that exactly as it appears online:
Every BSA activity should be supervised by a conscientious adult
who understands and knowingly accepts responsibility for the well-being
and safety of the children and youth in his or her care.
The supervisor should be sufficiently trained, experienced and skilled
in the activity to be confident of his or her ability to lead
and teach the necessary skills to respond effectively
in the event of an emergency
Field. knowledge of all applicable BSA standards
and a commitment to implement and follow BSA policy and procedures
are essential parts of the supervisor's qualification.
So let's parse that a little bit.
What qualifies any scout leader to supervise an average camp out?
Well, first, he or she understands the risk and accepts the responsibilities.
They're also familiar with and able to teach the necessary skills
and they're prepared to respond to emergencies.
They must be sufficiently trained, experienced and skilled.
Now there are three tests there for qualifying a person
to supervise a scouting activity.
They have to be trained, number one, experienced, number two
and skilled, number three.
You can't just be trained, you can't just be experienced,
or you can't just be skilled. You need to be all three.
Now, training: that's a fairly simple thing
and the BSA has provided wonderful resources for safety training.
If you haven't already, you need to make sure
that you take all of the safety training
that you can possibly take.
Most of those courses are online.
There's lightning safety or weather wise.
there's safety afloat. there's safe swim defense
and whether or not you think you're going on a swimming
or a float trip or you're going to be exposed
to harsh weather conditions or not, take all of them,
because it will start to get in your mind
the BSA approach to safety and it is extraordinarily important
and I hope that everyone takes advantage
of all of the safety training they can possibly get.
You have to match your experience and skill
to the activity and to the participants.
Let's take safe swim defense.
You're going to go someplace. there's a lake
and part of what you're planning on doing that weekend
is boys are going to go swimming.
First of all, have you been trained in safe swim defense?
Have you actually supervised scouts
when they've been swimming?
Do you have any experience and skill?
Your experience and skill is going to determine
how you apply your training.
The first few times you supervise scout swimming
using the safe swim defense,
you're going to be extraordinarily conservative
in your approach and as you gain skill and experience
you'll become more comfortable-
but never inattentive or cavalier-
in applying the training that you've been giving.
But you get more experience and you gain more skill.
When a new scout master goes camping,
they're going to supervise at a distance
that matches their training, ability and skill.
A brand new scout leader is going to spend more time
in a scout's campsite, observing without interfering,
until their experience and skill
permits them to, you know,
broaden the distance a little bit.
So what risks are involved in an average camping trip?
Well, we think of things like fire
and fire heats, water,
so hot liquids, you know, those moving around a campsite
that can be kind of dangerous
Edge tools like knives and hatchets and saws.
these are all pretty obvious risks.
Now, do we understand the risks?
Have we taught or overseen the teaching of the skills
to handle those risks safely?
What kind of experience do we have with them?
Do we review them constantly with our youth leaders
and our adult leaders?
Let's look at a very specific risk.
Let's look at knives or edge tools
like hatchets and saws?
Has every scout completed totenship training
before they start using those things in camp?
Are the safety practices taught by the totenship course
maintained by youth and adult leaders?
The totenship course doesn't eliminate risk.
I mean, one of the trips I took to the emergency room
was for a scout who managed to cut himself
to the extent where he needed eight stitches.
He did this with a pocket knife
and it happened about 20 minutes
after he had gotten his totenship card
And he was a few feet up from me at the time.
The only way I was going to prevent that accident
was to stand over the scout
and then grab the knife just before it sliced his thumb.
I'm not gifted with superhuman foresight,
so I ended up at the emergency room.
Now, was I adequately supervising the scout?
I would say yes.
Did he have the skills and training
to be able to prevent that accident?
Well, he had the training,
but he hadn't developed the experience or skills yet.
How can I be adequately supervising scouts
if they're out of sight?
Well, this guy was right there,
A couple feet away, Zingo cuts his thumb.
What I had done was I had done my best
to mitigate the risk and I used common sense.
So he was trained in totenship skills.
He had demonstrated that he knew them.
but you know he's a boy, he's inexperienced
and there's a cut.
Now, that's one out of hundreds of boys,
at times going camping.
So, as John mentioned in his e-mail,
you know injuries can happen.
accidents can happen when I'm standing right there.
So what's the difference between them happening right there
and those happening if the scouts are camped a distance from me?
Well, there really is no difference,
because what we're looking for is the proper application
of your training, experience and skills.
Now, in that case that I just described,
I applied my training experience and skills,
still had an accident. you know,
That's the way the ball bounces sometimes.
So let's talk about how do we apply training,
experience and skills supervising our scouts
if they're camped at some remove
from where the adults are camping.
Well, I ask a lot of questions
And by asking questions I assess risk
and I apply common sense.
I ask a patrol leader or senior patroller
what they will be doing.
If there's anything that sounds remotely
like it's a safety issue,
I'm going to ask them questions about mitigating risk
for that particular activity.
If I ask the senior patroller, I say:
what are you guys going to be doing.
Well, we're going to be gathering firewood,
Say, okay, you're going to be cutting the firewood,
Yeah,
What are you going to be using?
An axe?
Okay, so tell me about your axe yard.
Where have you set that up?
Tell me a couple of safety rules about hand axes.
If this is a new senior patrol leader
or a lot of inexperienced boys,
I might say: look, since you're doing this
for the first time, make sure to come and get me
before you start swinging any axes or hatchets
so I can look at and see what's happening.
When it's time to cook dinner,
I may wander through patrol campsite
or observe closely
and make sure that the campfire is okay,
make sure that the cooking setup is okay
and if I see any problems
or not, if I see problems or not,
I'm still going to ask questions.
What's going to happen if that pot of boiling water tips over?
Is there a better place you can set up your camp stove?
Is there a better setup for your campfire?
If it looks eminently dangerous, I'm going to stop it.
I'm going to stop it and I'm going to say:
look, guys, you're in a little bit of danger here.
so let me make some suggestions about how you can fix that.
You need to change the campfire setup this way.
You need to put the stove on a better ground.
You need to make sure that you have pot holders
before you mess around with that pot of hot water,
Just that type of thing.
I can do this without interfering,
without doing everything for them.
I assess risk and I supervise
that particular activity by asking questions.
If I'm sitting with my cup of coffee
in a remote campsite from the boys
and I hear some shouting,
what am I going to do?
I'm going to see what's going on.
If scouts are going to take off on a hike,
I want to know where they're going.
I want to know if they have a cell phone.
I want to know if they have a first aid kit.
I want to know if there's a signal for the cell phone.
I want to know what time they will return.
I want to look at the group of scouts that's going
and I want to assess whether or not
they're going to need a couple of older scouts along with them
or if they're going to need a couple of adults along with them.
If there's a shadow of a doubt,
I am going to do whatever I can
to apply my training, skills and experience
to mitigate whatever risks are present.
If we're camped near a body of water,
I'm going to ask my senior patrol leader
what the rules for swimming are.
I'm going to ask him if scouts have been reminded of them.
I'm going to ask him if he thinks they can go swimming or not.
You know- and they can't- unless an adult, trained
and safe twit swim defense is present.
I'm asking him if taking off your shoes
and raiding in the creek is a good idea,
Why or why not?
I ask about the buddy system.
I ask how they're managing the buddy system.
I ask a lot of questions, lots and lots of questions.
So what happens when a couple of scouts
sneak off and have a hatchet throwing contest?
What happens when somebody decides to see
what it's like if they throw a lighter into the fire?
Can I control or supervise scouts
who are willingly and knowingly
undertaking something in the contravention
of established safety standards?
Well, no, I can't.
And that's when I need to consider
0.8 of the Suite 16..
And 0.8 is skill level limits.
And I'm going to read exactly what that says:
There is a minimum skill level requirement
for every activity
And the supervisor must identify
and recognize this minimum skill level
and be sure that none are put at risk
by attempting activity beyond their ability.
So I have to know my scout's abilities.
Do I know my youth leaders well?
Do I know what their strengths and weaknesses are?
Have they demonstrated the ability to safely conduct
and supervise an activity they're about to undertake?
Do I need to have adults overseeing,
instructing, observing the activity,
or can we keep our distance?
Training experience and skill,
Asking lots and lots of questions,
Observing, without interfering?
All of these are important things.
You are going to do what you need to do
to make sure that your scouts are safe.
You're going to apply your training
according to your experience and skill.
So it's very important to me
that you don't listen to this podcast
or read the blog and get the wrong idea.
You know well, Clark said
we should camp away from the boys.
So let's give that a shot.
And you know you just camp away from the boys
and you don't apply your training, your skills
or your experience to mitigating risks.
That would not be common sense, would it?
If you are a brand new scout leader,
you're going to be a little bit closer to the situation
until you have the experience and the skills
to be able to assess risks,
to be able to know your scouts, know their abilities
and to help them design their activities
in accordance with those things.
A prudent leader who uses their common sense
is not going to ever ignore safety.
They're never going to think
well, you know, boys will be boys. what happens happens.
That's foolish.
What you're going to do is you're going to be trained,
and that's incredibly important.
You must. you must have every aspect
of safety training that you can possibly take,
whether you think you will ever apply it or not,
it's important.
You must review those things from time to time.
This is why most of the training, like safe swim defense
and weather wise and trek on safely,
are only good for two years,
Because two years later you need to go back
and see if there have been any changes
or there's been any improvement on the advice
and you need to retake the training.
These are not irksome or difficult things to do.
Actually, I welcome the idea
that I need to go back and get trained
every couple of years in these things.
I've been through safe swim defense
and safety afloat probably five or six times now,
But it's always good to renew it.
So your prudence and your common sense
are very, very important.
A sober assessment of your level of training,
your experience and your skills-
incredibly important.
So you adjust the way that you apply
the concept of scouts being scouts
camping away from the adults
to those things, to your training,
your experience and your skill level.
As you grow more comfortable and knowledgeable,
you'll be fine.
Now, in those instances where I've talked about
a troop trip that we've taken
and I may say: well, you know,
we were camped over here, the boys were camped over there.
Don't think for one minute
I did not have my mind
over in that scout campsite
And I was not thinking through
all of my training,
applying my experience and skills.
Don't think that I wasn't watching
what was going on.
Don't think that we weren't
observing and asking questions,
because that is a constant,
constant aspect of applying the scout program
and assuring the safety of our scouts.
John, I hope that helps.
I hope that helps everyone.
I'm sure there's going to be some questions generated
from this talk, so do send them to me
at scoutmastercgatverizonnet.
Well, thanks for listening
to this edition of the Scoutmaster podcast,
And here's how you can keep in touch,
using the full spectrum
of all available social media outlets.
It is getting a little crazy out there, isn't it.
But first of all, you can come
and visit us at the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
When you do go there, you'll find
that you can subscribe to posts from the blog
and subscribe to the Scoutmaster newsletter,
which is hopefully a monthly digest
of the Scoutmaster blog and podcast.
And we're a little behind
on getting the Scoutmaster newsletter out
right now, like a month,
But it's been a busy scouting season
so folks bear with me.
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes and when you do,
feel free to leave a comment or review or rating,
You can call.
That's kind of old-fashioned, isn't it?
But you can call this phone number
and you can leave a comment or question
at 4-8-4-7-3-4-0-0-0-2..
And you can follow us at
Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and ScoutmasterCG on Twitter.
And if you're on Google Plus,
search for Clark Green
and we'll put you in the
ScoutmasterCG Circle.
How about that?
If you're really old-fashioned,
you can get in touch with me via email-
Email's old-fashioned, I guess.
You can write me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
at ScoutmasterCG
at Verizonnet-
ScoutmasterCG
at Verizonnet.
People sometimes ask, so I tell you:
the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
You need to measure everything that I say
and all my advice against official
policy and procedure
on the Boy Scouts of America website
at scoutingorg.
If I'm not right about things
or if I've gotten something back to front,
you get in touch and let me know.
Really,
This is just me talking into a microphone
to lend a hand to Scout leaders
and perhaps have a little bit of fun along the way.
Before I leave you for this podcast,
let's hear
from the dim-distant past
and the founder of Scouting, Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
I highly recommend
the Scoutmaster podcast.
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.
Thank you.